est-ce que vous connaissez le pansement
connecté la technologie est vraiment
partout on la retrouve même au niveau de
la science au niveau de la médecine il
arrive que certains patients et des
plaies chroniques avec des difficultés à
cicatriser justement il y a trois
inventeurs de génie qui ont une superbe
idée l'idée d'avoir un pansement qui est
totalement connecté on va retrouver à
l'intérieur un capteur de pH permettra
de connaître l'état de cicatrisation de
la peau et votre pension va connecter
avec les équipes grâce à une puce RFID
l'idée est juste géniale et permettra à
énormément de personnes souffrant de
plaies chroniques une cicatrice pas ou
très peu ou très mal de pouvoir
cicatriser tranquillement parce que le
vrai risque lors de la cicatrisation
c'est de retirer le pansement pour
connaître l'état de cicatrisation de
l'appeler et de faire rentrer des germes
et notamment avoir des infections alors
cette invention est pas totalement
disponible pour l'instant déteste
doivent continuer à être fait et ensuite
il y aura des essais cliniques pour un
lancement potentiel en 2025 en tout cas
l'invention a gagné le James Dyson Award
qui leur permet d'avoir un vrai coup de
projecteur et une aide pour le
développement de leurs produits je
trouve ça juste génial dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez vous dans les
commentaires